chinese kovit 19 vaccines are being used
in dozens of countries
china has donated vaccines
everywhere for those countries who need
help but these shots have some of the
lowest efficacy rates among globally
used coronavirus vaccines
ranging between 50 to nearly 80 percent
compare this with shots from pfizer
biontech moderna and russia's sputnik v
the head of china's cdc in early april
said the efficacy of some vaccines was
not high
and this also included ones from his own
country so china is looking to bolster
the protection rate
and one way is to mix and match
different types of vaccines
and this idea isn't new we really
welcome studies that would look at mix
and match regimens
spain is also interested in combining
vaccines while researchers in the uk and
russia
are already studying this so as china
joins the ranks of countries looking to
mix and match
here's how it can be a key to overcoming
multiple vaccination challenges
at once most chinese vaccines and other
shots currently in use
require two doses creating an
opportunity to mix and match
some immunologists believe this could
have a number of benefits
like boosting the immune response the
theory is that if you
train the immune system to recognize a
virus in a slightly different way each
time then you might get a broader and
more durable
immune response and a more robust immune
response is important since china has
confirmed cases of new and more
transmissible variants that were first
identified in the uk and south africa
mixing and matching for this reason has
gotten support from at least one chinese
drug maker so far
some immunologists also say that mixing
and matching could ease the pressure
from the vaccine supply chain
so for example in countries that are
rolling out chinese vaccines along with
other supplies
using two different shots could give
doctors more options when patients come
in for the second dose
but one of the most important reasons is
when there are severe side effects from
one of the vaccines
if someone perhaps has a strange or
severe allergic reaction to the first
shot that they get perhaps then you
could avoid that by giving them
the second dose from a different vaccine
the idea became particularly important
after regulators started investigating
rare blood clotting disorders linked to
astrazeneca's coveted vaccine
as of late march 79 people in the uk
have had severe blood clots out of the
20 million administered doses of
astrazeneca's vaccine
in france and germany health authorities
are advising younger people who have
received a first dose of astrazeneca
to get a second dose of a different
vaccine the drug maker said it's working
with health regulators and studying the
rare blood clotting events and possible
causes
while these upsides could bring china
and other countries closer to getting
their population vaccinated
health authorities say there's still a
lot to learn about possible side effects
or how it may affect efficacy of the
vaccines especially when it comes to
combining shots made with different
technologies
vaccines such as the chinese vaccine and
vaccines by astrozenic and johnson
johnson are
vaccines that use a virus as the vector
to get the
genetic instructions into your body
whereas pfizer biontec
and moderna vaccines use a new
gene-based technology involving
messenger rna
where molecules carry genetic
instructions so we're not too sure what
happens when you mix these two
technologies together
chinese health authorities have said
people can receive different brands that
use the same technology
but don't recommend mixing vaccines with
different technologies so far
but now trials with the combination of
two homegrown vaccines with different
technologies
are underway in china with more than a
hundred volunteers
the country is also working on its own
mrna vaccine and looking closely at
approving pfizer biontech's shot
according to people familiar with the
matter this would pave the way for china
to mix and match its more conventional
vaccines with
mrna shots similar to how researchers in
the uk are studying the combination of
astrazeneca
with pfizer biontec or moderna those
results are expected as early as may
immunologists when you speak them about
this this sort of process
are pretty enthusiastic about it and
optimistic that it's going to work but
that's maybe the one big draw because we
want to make sure that it works we want
to make sure that it isn't
worse you don't get a worse immune
response than if you had
two doses of the same vaccine